>> IT'S FRIDAY.
FINALLY TONIGHT NOTABLE
QUOTEABLES.
>> HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE A
>> DOESN'T HAPPEN JUNE 12th,
IT COULD HAPPEN THEREAFTER.
>> THE SUMMIT IS ON TRACK.
MAYBE NOT FOR JUNE 12th.
>> IT'S PROBABLY LIKELY TO BE
DELAYED.
>> THE PROCESS WILL BEGIN ON
JUNE 12th IN SINGAPORE.
>> YOU'LL SEE PLENTY OF
ALUMINUM/STEEL AROUND, JUST MADE
BY AMERICAN HANDS.
>> NOT REALLY THE GREAT VACATION
I WAS LOOKING FOR, BUT WE'RE
STILL TOGETHER.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO RELATIONSHIPS
TO MY WIFE FOR THE HELL SHE'S
HAD TO GO THROUGH THE PAST TWO
DAYS.
>> CAN YOU TELL ME WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL DO TO
PREVENT THESE SENSELESS
TRAGEDIES?
>> THERE'S NOTHING MORE
TERRIFYING FOR A KID TO GO TO
SCHOOL AND NOT FEEL SAFE.
>> THEY GAVE UP TWO LIVES FOR
THEIR COUNTRY.
THE ONE THEY WERE LIVING AND THE
ONE THEY WOULD HAVE LIVED.
>> I'M FINE.
I'M WORRIED ABOUT THE PEOPLE OUT
THERE WHO DON'T HAVE A CIRCLE OF
FRIENDS.
>> I CANNOT ALLOW THOSE FORCES
TO CONTINUE TO CAUSE PAIN AND
DIFFICULTY TO THE PEOPLE THAT I
LOVE.
>> EVERY TIME IT RAINS HARD, YOU
SAY A HAIL MARY AND HOPE IT'S
NOT THE TIME.
HERE WE ARE.
IT WAS TIME.
>> THERE'S JUST NOTHING TO FOOL
WITH.
>> THERE'S LOTS OF REALLY
LAWYERS IN COUNTRY.
HE COULD HAVE PICKED SOMEONE
ELSE.
>> JUST SAY IMPEACHMENT,
SWEETHEART.
JUST SAY IT.
>> IF I HAD THAT FACE, THAT HEAD
OF HAIR, I WOULD HAVE BEEN
PRESIDENT SO LONG AGO.
>> PRESIDENT REALLY?
I NEVER QUITE SAW THIS.
>> DO I HAVE SOCIAL SKILLS?
I DON'T KNOW.
I HAVE SOCIAL MEDIA, THAT'S FOR